ladies and gentlemen bill
bird
thank you
thank you all right thanks a lot
thank you so much
thank you for christ's sake
thank you
thanks a lot
i'm running out of ways to say thank you
for christ's sake
how's it going
excellent
i was in a shitty mood today man
it was i was watching tv
you ever been in like such a bad mood
that even when you're watching bad [ __ ]
happening to people you're like you know
what good
you know i'm glad your life sucks
makes me feel better about my own
no you know what i was doing i was
watching this uh you know those fabulous
lives i was watching the the fabulous
life of the olsen twins you know
they're like 18 years old they're like
zillionaires
we got a great apartment it's making me
feel like a loser
then halfway through it i find out one
of them's anorexic i was like you know
what all right
it makes me feel better
you know i'm glad she's not eating
i hope you pass out whack your head off
your golden sink
just to add to my day
you know i don't get i don't get how the
other olson twin only weighs half a
pound more but she's [ __ ] fine
[Applause]
no they're so starving they're weak
that's why whenever they take a picture
of them you haven't noticed they gotta
like [ __ ] lean them up against each
other
it's like they don't tip over like
they're like still trying to look sexy
[Applause]
they're not sexy they look like aliens
they are man you can't weigh 42 pounds
and have your eyeballs be 28 of that
weight
and not look like you're from outer
space
like when i look at them i think if e.t
was gonna have a threesome those are the
two [ __ ] he'd hook up with
he would he'd get that glowing finger
going
[Applause]
now i feel like a loser man
hey man i'm [ __ ] 36 i'm not married
you know i'm at that age where everybody
knows getting married you know let me
ask you a question why the hell do
people keep getting married
you know isn't anybody looking at the
stats
i mean what's it like one out of two
marriages goes right down the [ __ ]
people if you were going skydiving and
they told you half the parachutes
weren't gonna open
you'd be like yo [ __ ] that i'm not going
damn
now it's like
i don't like those odds i get a 50
chance of splatting on the ground i'm
not doing it right but there's something
about getting married people just have
to do it they're just like is this the
line to lose half my ship awesome
this is gonna be great
i can't wait to lose my car my money oh
look the line's moving one step closer
to my own personal hell
[Applause]
no i don't think i could ever get
married man
married dudes freak me out
anytime you ask a married guy what's it
like being married they always tell you
it's good but they always have a look on
their face like they have like an
appendicitis you haven't noticed that
you're like dude what's it like being
married like you know it's good it's
good it's uh
no no it's good it's enjoyable you know
it's a lot of work but uh you know i
think when you meet that special someone
there's a connection and i can't feel my
legs let me just lean over here
you know a woman completes a man and
some other metaphor
now you know what freaks me out too
really when you go to a man's house
there's nothing in there a married guy's
house when you walk in there there's
nothing in there that even suggests a
man even lives there
it's all potpourri and throw pillows
that stupid canopy we live in a
dollhouse [ __ ] over the bed
where does all the guys stuff go
they just throw it out they just walk in
your apartment oh my god look at all
your stuff
all your stuff is stupid
look at all this stupid stuff
wow guys buy really stupid stuff hey you
want to go to the candle store
let's go to the candle store wouldn't
that be awesome they've been dragged
into that nightmare for like an hour and
a half
90 minutes just sitting there this
smells like a pumpkin and that's not
like a pumpkin
that sounds like a christmas tree
wouldn't that be great i like christmas
in the apartment middle of summer just
[ __ ] with your whole reality
[Applause]
no you know what it is i didn't have
like a really good model necessarily
like growing up like watching my parents
they always used to argue and [ __ ] you
know like i was afraid of my dad when i
was growing up you know anybody have a
dad like that you're just afraid of them
you know not like those sitcom dads they
come home the kids are like hugging
their legs
my dad pulls in the driveway you mean my
brother's freak's like [ __ ] dad's
home
shut off the tv
try to hide dude if i stand like this do
i look like a lamp he won't see me right
can i just [ __ ] chill out here
[Applause]
he wasn't understanding
when you [ __ ] up he told you
you didn't sit down while we're gonna
work it out we'll just you know i still
love you you what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
jesus christ you're an idiot
weren't you even paying attention
now [ __ ]
christ you're just like your mother
you're [ __ ] out to lunch
that was my dad no matter what he was
bitching about somehow he would make it
about my mother would have nothing to do
nothing to do with her he could somehow
find a connection and spin it back
peter said i was it raining out for
christ's sake i don't need this [ __ ]
christ it's the same goddamn thing with
your mother that woman is a [ __ ]
cloud hanging over my life
anytime you got an idea why she shits
all over it
[Applause]
no he was hilarious
he used to work all the time so he
didn't really have like any friends or
anything he used to talk to me
when i was eight years old like i was a
[ __ ] bartender
just dumping all this [ __ ] on me
like playing in the sandbox he'd be
coming up i'll tell you i don't know
what the [ __ ] i ever got married for
i'll tell you man i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
out i swear to god one of these days
when get in the car i'm gonna [ __ ]
drive out of here your mother's a [ __ ]
billy do you realize that the woman is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
is that too real for you guys you
[ __ ] know what i'm talking about
i will get married you know
i was making that i'll definitely get
married someday you know i you know i
love women and everything i'm just
finding i'm not like compatible with
them you know what i mean
if i just feel that like women have like
too much energy for me you know what i
mean like you can't have a day off when
you have a girlfriend you don't notice
that it's almost like they see that open
day they're like oh my god let's go fill
it up with [ __ ]
no then they just come at you
with one horrible idea after another
horrible ideas like you want to make
some sandwiches and go to the park
you want to go to the container store
get some containers for your t-shirts
this is the worst one
you ever get this one you want to go to
brunch
you want to go to brunch on sunday
and inside you're like [ __ ] no
but you can't say that right
you got to keep them happy so what do
you do you agree like yeah let's go to
brunch
what a great idea
why would you want to sleep in on a
sunday when you can go pay 18 for eggs
now you think it
now you're thinking
now we can sit around to listen to your
friends have moronic conversations about
the eggs like is that pesto
is that pesto in your omelet
oh it's asparagus
it's asparagus i thought it was pesto
oh you just want to flip the whole
[ __ ] table
[Applause]
it's
over
i'm trying to learn to pick my battles
when i date girls i usually argue with
women all the time man i'm stupid like
that you know like i dated this girl one
time she was like really into like
women's
so we used to always have these dumb ass
arguments so one time she came up to me
she goes okay explain this to me bro why
does a guy make more an hour to do the
exact same job huh
i go i'll tell you why because in the
unlikely event that we're both on a
titanic and it starts to sink for some
[ __ ] up reason you get to leave with
the kids and i have to stay
[Applause]
hey that's why i get the delamar now
no think about it if there's a house
fire it's always women and children
first i got to stand there with like the
back of my shirt on fire going let's go
people let's go let's go
so that's how i look at it no it's a
dollar an hour surcharge
that if something [ __ ] up happens
either i can't leave or i gotta like get
in the way of it to give you a head
start like rabid dog run honey one
mississippi two
mississippi
you hear a bump in the night i gotta go
check it out like yes he does have a
knife
[Applause]
anytime there's a hostage situation who
do they negotiate for first well at
least let the women and children go
what about me
bullets hurt me too why the [ __ ] do i
gotta stay in the vault
no that's my point man
where are all the feminists in those
situations
you know what i mean you can't find them
there are no feminists in a house fire
that's a it's a guarantee
you could take the most hardcore
feminist some chick right in your face
like he showed me to take down a [ __ ] a
little short little haircut the whole
nine yards right
second those flames break out she's
gonna twist those little hairs into
pigtails no i'm just a girl i want to go
play jump rope
and leave you standing in a burning
house like you're not flammable
you know but i'm not a dick though
i'm not i'm not saying i think a woman
should make a doll less an hour to do
the same job all i'm saying is if you're
gonna make what i make when the boat
sinks you better be standing right there
next to me listen to that guy play the
cello then you get the corner office
get all the benefits or whatever
so anyways i was watching uh george bush
today man that guy scares the [ __ ] on me
no not because like all you know all
that political stuff he's just like two
into jesus for me
i get uncomfortable with that when
people get like overly religious it kind
of freaks me out you know
you know what i mean like
like i don't mind
i don't mind when like black people get
really into jesus though you know
because like somehow like the [ __ ] stay
spiritual
you know you get a couple of good songs
out of it
you know make people look like they're
having a good time
somehow when like white dudes get tuned
to jesus all of a sudden like [ __ ]
catches on fire
people start dying somebody says they're
jesus and they try to [ __ ] every chick
in the compound
then the fbi's got the place surrounded
that tank comes in shooting the flames
out the front
and i'm not saying white dudes are any
more crazier than black dudes it's just
that nobody's watching us
that's the problem
that's too much freedom
it's kind of like living alone you know
that same kind of [ __ ] up freedom
you ever feel when you live alone you
like slowly go crazy
you know because you got too much
freedom because everybody does crazy
[ __ ] but when you live alone and start
doing something crazy there's nobody
there to be like dude what the [ __ ] are
you doing
what what is wrong with you what is that
put it down
[Applause]
my girl's actually she's really like
religious she goes to church every week
and i never go and it freaks her out
she's like why don't you go to church
you don't believe in god and heaven and
hell and all that stuff
why don't you go
and it's not because i don't believe in
a higher power i definitely do my thing
is when i go to church i can't get past
the fact that i'm just listening to some
[ __ ] guy
you ever think of that [ __ ] when you go
in there
that's just some dude
and people like no that's a special guy
no it isn't
it isn't
ah he didn't he didn't like levitate
down from the ceiling like
this white light around him
why would you listen to another human
being tell you where you're gonna go
when you die
it's just like dude have you ever been
dead no great so wouldn't it be safe to
assume that you wouldn't have the
slightest [ __ ] idea what you're
talking about
yeah you're making it up
you're making the [ __ ] up
you're not fooling me with the robes and
the candles
speaking in old english he said it
thunder you wish shut the [ __ ] up you
don't talk like that
you're just some guy your name's jerry
you played soccer you got your ass
kicked in gym class and how you doing
this
is acting like you're special
i can't do it i just i can't get past
that fact i'm sitting in church this
guy's name's [ __ ] cliff
he's [ __ ] boring i just break the guy
down and then i can't listen it's like
you're going there you listen to another
human being tell you what to eat and
when to eat it
don't eat meat this friday
if you eat meat this friday you are
going to hell
it's like dude i'm going to a cookout on
friday if you eat that [ __ ]
cheeseburger buddy
that is it for you
but where's this guy dude i'll eat a
cheeseburger whenever i want to and i'll
jerk off it's my dick
why am i listening to this guy
i'll [ __ ] jerk off while i eat a
cheeseburger what do you think about
that
i'm not hurting anybody why would god
care
i'm not hurting anybody think about it
you eat a cheeseburger that's protein
that's good for your muscles right
and i don't know about you guys but
after i rub one out i'm more relaxed
i'm less likely to lash out at my fellow
man
i'm in a great space mentally
i don't have any road rage i talk to
telemarketers i'm buying the [ __ ]
i think they just they just make it all
up
but it's weird though because i'm kind
of feeling this thing because i haven't
been churching a while i'm kind of
feeling like you know i want to go back
but i need a new religion man that's i'm
kind of between religions right now you
know like i used to be catholic but you
know i can't be catholic anymore you
know i mean once they started [ __ ]
the kids i was just like all right dude
you know what i'm out okay
you guys party way too [ __ ] hard for
me okay
i got off at about 22 exits ago
i didn't see that page in the book i
don't know what you guys are doing
i can't believe they're still in
business
people are still showing up
name one other business that could
survive that [ __ ]
you think if they were [ __ ] kids at
walmart they could sell rakes the next
day
and just try to play it off like yeah we
had a little problem in aisle eight but
you know we got some slacks over here
we got kitchen appliances
we got some hula hoops
you guys saw the pope died he saw that
right
yeah everyone's flipping out man i
thought that was a good thing
i was like happy for man he was in
horrible health
you know what i mean everybody just
wanted a guy to keep hanging on
it's ridiculous they're like wheeling
them from room to room and
people are still flipping i can't i
think he's gonna die i
think he's gonna die
it's like well i think he's gonna go to
heaven i mean
it's gotta be better than that [ __ ]
i bet the last two months of his life he
was just sitting in that chair going god
i wish the world would stop praying for
me
just [ __ ] let me go
good lord
i skied till i was 78. i had a great
life
move on
[Applause]
so they got a new pulp now they picked
another old white dude you know and uh
they were actually in the running was
this black dude from nigeria right they
actually considering making him the pope
and i was kind of hoping he was going to
win you know not because i give a [ __ ]
either way i just want to see all the
black comics doing bits like the next
day like oh why people scared now
white people is scared now
yeah the pope is black and [ __ ]
it's gonna be a whole different story
he's gonna come in with the hat to the
side
gonna be pumping
white people in the front row gee i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on
because when black people go to church
[Applause]
could you just feel it
that was like a half hour material went
out the [ __ ] window the second they
picked another white dude
it was endless
pope mobile is gonna be pimped out and
you better not be shooting at this pope
the black pope will be shooting back at
your ass
cause when white people get shot etc etc
actually i have this black dude moved in
my building man lives on the same floor
as me he's one of these dudes every time
he's he's hilarious every time he says
some [ __ ] right after he's done saying
the [ __ ] he repeats like the most
important part of like the previous
sentence
it's hilarious everything he said yo my
man came in he put that [ __ ] on the
table put it on the table
it's hilarious
everything he says
[Applause]
no this country's at war son
i'm just looking at my friend like dude
did you hear him the first time because
i heard him the first time i was smiling
i was nodding
am i my [ __ ] supposed to do that what
am i supposed to do
[Applause]
actually i got a couple of uh friends of
uh african persuasion
and uh i gotta get rid of them man i
gotta admit to you
i'm finding i'm spending too much money
on clothes hanging out with them because
i gotta like [ __ ] try to keep up with
their wardrobe
it's like every time they go out they
got all brand new [ __ ] on
all brand new [ __ ] so when i show up
with my white version of brand new which
is you know i basically i ironed the
[ __ ] right i ironed it right it's true
they just start trashing me
i can't keep up with them man they got
like [ __ ]
58
pairs of sneakers
ever notice that [ __ ] like every color
[ __ ] timberland and i don't give a
[ __ ] what [ __ ] up color their shirt is
they got a pair of shoes to match it and
a hat
it's like a rule or something
they're the worst even when you wear
some new [ __ ] there's like some sort of
rule that you got to like space out the
amount of time within which like that
you wear it because god forbid you wear
the same shirt within a 10-day period
one of them's gonna notice
the old son just look at you funny like
this motherfucker's got the same [ __ ] he
had on last tuesday
and then the whole car is like oh [ __ ]
then everybody just starts making fun of
you [ __ ] close
first they do the math like what was
that five days ago five days this
[ __ ] got five shirts
he got five shirts
they start breaking it down yo his first
shirt he's saying monday next [ __ ] he's
saying tuesday
during the weekend he ain't wearing no
shirt
i'll tell you that's actually funny you
know what that's actually how i judge
black guys now
when i first came to the city like all
black people scared me
was like the typical white dude from
like the suburbs you know what i mean
had no frame of reference you know it's
my only frame of reference with black
people was like those remember those
early 90s gangster rap videos
throw the [ __ ] la riots in there man
it was [ __ ] horrible pr
i'm watching the video so he's got nice
car he's got all the women and he's
still [ __ ] mad
these black dudes are never happy
but after 10 years of living in the sea
this is how i narrow it down whether
black dude scares me now black dudes
with dirty sneakers scare the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me
no
i figured out my head because i know
from hanging out with them that's the
last [ __ ] that they're gonna let go the
immediate [ __ ] that they have on so i
think you know if his sneakers are
[ __ ] up that means his life is [ __ ]
up
every time he leaves his building the
whole neighborhood oh [ __ ]
everyone sucks making fun of him
he's on the train in a bad mood i kind
of have this howdy duty kind of mug me
kind of face
i'm not saying something's gonna happen
i'm just saying i'm paying attention
so i've been seeing this girl recently
uh it's black girl right she lives up in
harlem you know gone out like three four
times you know first time we hung out we
hung out like the village area in new
york you know which is sort of like a
racially mixed area
so [ __ ] was cool you know what i mean
second time you hung out was more like
midtown you know then the third time she
called me at like 3 30 in the morning
and she wanted me to come up to her
apartment right
so it's 3 30 in the morning she lives in
harlem i look how i look so it's a
[ __ ] situation
yeah because you know the deal right
basically a white dude feels comfortable
up to about like 98 99th street you know
what i'm saying
the second the streets start getting
into like triple digits like 100 101st
street start getting like a little
asthma like [ __ ] i'm starting to get a
little high up here
you feel that little tightness in your
chest can you feel that
106th street you're like leaning on [ __ ]
like dude where'd all the cabs go
how come there's no taxis up here
dude what's a bodega
i don't know what that is let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
so i'm praying to god she's gonna tell
me to take the subway get off at like
105th street 130 you know which is like
the first stop in harlem where i can
still look over my shoulder and see like
all the white people like disappearing
over the horizon you know
but she goes no man you want to get on
the uptown 2-3 train you want to get off
at 125th stream like ah [ __ ] on 25th
street
jesus christ that's like right in the
middle of everything
i'm gonna be surrounded on all four
sides i can't [ __ ] do this
so
at this point i'm really trying to hide
like the [ __ ] tone that's starting to
creep into my voice you know
and i'm trying to ask for really
specific directions for when i get up
there because i want to know exactly
where i'm going
so she starts naming the streets i have
to go down and every other street up
there is named that's like a black
leader you know she's like make a left
on adam clayton take a right on
frederick douglas i'm like [ __ ] kind of
quick
now dude go on the internet look at that
and clayton
did he kill a bunch of white people
during the slaver boat
dude i'm going up there so i know what
i'm saying to [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Applause]
so at this point i'm really having a
battle with myself
because i'm thinking i can't do this
right i'm like i can't do this but my
dick's going now come on man we can do
this all right
just relax
pull yourself together and get on the
goddamn train right
so as always i listen to my
dick oh yeah i get on the train by the
time i get up there it's like five or
four in the morning right i'm staying on
like malcolm x and like danny glover or
some [ __ ] right
i don't even know where the hell i'm at
when i see the street i want to go up i
want to go up saint nick i can literally
see her apartment building but there's
like five or six black dudes standing
right on the corner right where i want
to walk by so i'm like [ __ ]
i thought i was on like some reality
show at that point like some sort of
like white guy survivor it was
ridiculous
so i'm thinking i got to walk right by
these guys right you know what's funny i
think that they were actually more
surprised to see me than i was scared
you know and i was really really scared
you know but i'm also really really
white you know
like shockingly caucasian
you know like if you're not ready for me
i can like surprise you
no especially if you live up there
you've probably seen a white person for
hours
possibly days so when i show up it's
almost like magical like a leprechaun
came out of nowhere you know
felt like i should have like a little
pot of gold
like a rainbow behind me top of the
morning to your latte
kind of dance my way past them
[Applause]
but it's been going all right you know
once i get in her apartment i'm fine you
know i relax
sit down you know watch a hip-hop
countdown
pretend like i know the groups you know
what i mean
it's just getting there that's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass
but you know i don't get mad at it
because i figure you know black dude's
got to go through the same [ __ ] though
right when you go into the suburbs go
[ __ ] a white girl
right
just that same awful feeling
of just leaving your people behind you
know just less and less of you as you're
[ __ ] driving out there probably start
off lean and you're all [ __ ] cool
20 minutes in you're driving like 10 and
two the waves off like dude i like this
[ __ ]
i don't like this [ __ ] at all
there's too much grass i don't see any
rims
this is [ __ ] up none of the windows
are tinted i can clearly see white
people in every car this is [ __ ] up
listen you guys were awesome thank you
so much for coming out
god bless you thank you very much
all right man take care thank you
you